i want to talk about new year's coming
up new year's
is my favorite time of year it's it's
like we all get this collective
mulligan it's like no matter how we
started we all get to the end of the
year
and you can walk around on january 1st
wearing
all polka dots you can walk around with
a
wheelbarrow full of rocks and someone's
like what are you doing like hey it's
new year's resolution bro and they're
like oh cool man no matter what it is
you're doing
i'm on the all chocolate marshmallow
diet i'm only eating
raw vegetables and ponies and whatever
the thing is you can say whatever you
want everyone's like well that's cool
man whatever
i love new years but one thing i've
noticed over the last few years is this
obsession not last few years forever
right i've been obsessed with this
forever
but i've noticed it rising at the top
this idea of these
goals we are obsessed with goals
one of my mentors dr stephen bonner was
called recently and was talking about a
book he was reading
that suggested data is a new
is our new addiction our new cultural
addiction is data
if you can't measure it it's not real
if i can't touch it it's not there if i
can't see it it doesn't exist
and what happens is we get paralyzed
without data companies are just
with a magnifying glass looking at all
of the data so where you used to step
back and look at trends hey we're all
headed this direction
people are screaming and yelling by
every little
nook and cranny of the every little
lightning bolt every little this and
that and this and that and that and this
and it's making us nuts and it's a
numbing device
i'm not going to move until i look at
the data i'm not going to do anything
until i see the data
we can't do anything unless we got goals
and you can't have goals without metrics
and you can't have metrics without
measurement tools etc etc and what
happens is
we all become a series of achievements
i wanted to do these things i wanted to
achieve these things i want to look at
my data and decide
am i successful or am i a failure
and i've decided that's a terrible
terrible way to go through life
instead this year i want you to
reimagine
goals i want you to back out of your
life as a life
of only achievement and successes and
accomplishments
and i want you to begin to think of who
are you now i have not read
james clear's book called atomic habits
i've heard it's excellent and i was
talking through this with somebody the
other day and they're like man
that sounds just like that book so i'm
gonna pick up that book i've actually
met james like
i know he's a brilliant guy and that
this book has remained on the best
seller list i think is pretty good
um and so it may be a worthy read for
everybody i'll go ahead and recommend it
here
but i think what i'm going to talk about
similar and that's this
instead of imagining the goals and
achievements and successes i want you to
begin to think of
who you are and this sounds like
semantics but it's a much
deeper picture instead of asking what am
i going to do this year
i want you to start asking who am i or
what kind of person am i going to be
so here's the way that plays out in real
life instead of looking at your
um your new year's resolutions
i'm gonna lose 35 pounds i'm going to
run a marathon i'm going to bench press
250 pounds
fill in the blank instead i want you to
make your resolution i'm going to commit
to being a person who's a good steward
of my body
i'm going to be a person who commits to
being a good steward of my body
i'm going to be the kind of person that
can play with my grandkids on the ground
when i'm 85.
i'm that kind of person and what you're
going to find
is when you are that kind of person
that kind of person exercises that kind
of person
mostly eats right and that kind of
person dances
and plays and that kind of person laughs
and that kind of person
sleeps so it's a much bigger picture
then underneath that once you've
identified who you want to be what kind
of person are you
what are your values what are your
character then you can set a goal i'm
going to run a marathon with some
friends i want to do something hard
but instead of i want to run two
marathons maybe i want to be the kind of
person who does hard things
who challenges myself
and then training for a marathon is a
hard challenge right
and again it sounds like semantics but
the goal is i'm a person who does hard
things so i was talking to my good
friend george camo here we were on
another podcast he works here
at ramsey solutions and he was showing
me his
list from last year his resolutions and
they were i'm going to learn this many
songs this week
i'm going to write this much stuff i'm
going to this and this and this
and he's like man i look at this and i
failed 20 20.
and i was like dude no you didn't so we
stepped back and i said
i want to take this i'm going to write
this many songs i'm going to record an
album i'm going to
learn how to play this guitar solos
whatever
and instead of identifying a success or
a failure as
i achieved these things
step back and say i want to be a person
who creates
i want to be a person who is a creative
person who puts new things out into the
world
when i step back and looked at it that
way with george
he's created a ton of new content he's
spun out a new podcast that he is
leading he has
um recorded a number of videos
and um cool ways that ramsey solutions
is approaching money
he has come up with new stand-up comedy
routines he's been
come up with new things for a number of
live events that he emcees
he's had an incredibly creative year
just didn't write an album and that
doesn't mean he failed this year that
mean this year happened to him
and fill in the blank so instead of
saying
i'm going to learn two songs each week
on a guitar i'm going to paint a picture
every week
commit to being a person who creates or
who's creative
because a person will go garden design a
school curriculum come up with
extraordinary work presentations write
grad school papers
figure out how to cook new and inventive
healthy meals
learn what her husband loves or doesn't
love lean into learning a
totally new love language and that is
creative
and it may not be learning a song or two
on the guitar
if you want to be a person who does hard
things i'm going to force
myself i'm going to force myself to
learn a song every year every
every week all right now you're doing it
for a different reason because you're
doing it for an identity
i commit to being a disciplined person i
commit to being a person who learns
that means i'm going to read i'm going
to listen to podcasts i'm going to talk
to smart people
i'm going to to talk to experienced
people
once you've decided who you're going to
be then you get to add some discipline
beneath it that doesn't mean we don't
have goals it doesn't mean we don't want
to achieve things
but that means those come second those
come next
to deciding who do we want to be this
year
and so in the next show or two we're
going to have a new year special show
because i love new year's
i'm going to talk about who i'm going to
commit to be this year
i want you to be thinking through who
are you going to commit to being
if you're driving in a car back from the
holidays
with your girlfriend or boyfriend or
spouse only all to talk about
who do you want to be this year what is
the
type of person you're going to commit to
being and then what are the things that
you're going to do
underneath that type of commitment
and if you are about the process i'll
end this with the process
so those of you know i attended and
worked at texas tech university
they have a basketball coach there named
chris beard and
you can look it up on youtube it's a
great interview they talked about
somebody's asking how many wins are you
going to have and he said i don't care
and they were like excuse me you're a
division one power five conference uh
basketball coach you've won
championships everywhere you went
what do you mean you don't care about
wins he said i care about the process
and he rattled off real quick the
process
every day of his players we will wake up
at 6 00 am we will eat a healthy
breakfast we will
meditate and pray or look at our
affirmations and then we will go
exercise
we will exercise as a team and then we
will go to class we will sit in the
front row and we will wear a tie
and an end and he went about the process
here's the process of being a person of
character here's the process of person
who stewards their body
here's the process of being a teammate
who's not only in this for themselves
but for other people if you take care of
the process
every day then by and large the winds
will take care of themselves and as he
said
sometimes the ball just bounces out
sometimes the ball just hits somebody's
elbow and bonks off somebody's head and
it goes out of bounds and the game's
over you lose
but if you take care of the process
winds start to take care of themselves
if you get obsessed with winning that's
when you cut corners
that's when you start taking diet pills
to lose weight that's when you starve
yourself
that's when you start looking in the
mirror and thinking i'm not beautiful
i'm not stewarding my body
i'm drawing just to get ripped and you
start
eating things that aren't good for you
you start doing things i just want to be
a better husband well man then your wife
becomes a project not a partner right
so focus on the process focus on
character focus on who you want to be
focus on what you want to be this year
get somebody you can talk to about it
and we will
put it in concrete we'll write it down
at the next show